a court in Pakistan has granted former
prime minister Imran Khan two weeks bail
he's facing multiple charges that
include corruption on Thursday the
Supreme Court ruled that his arrest
earlier in the week was unlawful
Khan's detention sparked days of
protests by his supporters police
imposed emergency orders Banning public
Gatherings ahead of his court appearance
let's go live now to Islamabad Al jazeer
as Osama bin Javed is there for us tell
us more about what happened in court
today
but it's been a day of extraordinary uh
relief for Imran Khan where he's not
just being granted bail in the case that
he was demanded in custody of the
national accountability Bureau on
corruption charges but he's also been
granted uh relief in any cases that he
doesn't even know about so there were
multiple benches at the Islamabad High
Court which provided Imran Khan this
reprieve from being arrested by the
police or any other government body and
saying that even under the maintenance
public order act under which many of
Imran Khan's Party leaders have been
arrested the police cannot arrest him it
appears that Imran Khan is going to be
moving from the court to his residence
in Lahore according to the latest
information but he's been waiting to get
the written order before he leaves the
court as he said earlier that he fears
that he'd be booked and sent to jail in
another case talking to journalists
right after getting bailed he accused
the country's Army chief for being the
biggest risk to him he said the military
is being maligned because of one man the
Army chief of Pakistan and he said that
he is going to continue uh to come out
and thank the Judiciary for giving him
this this opportunity to go back and
continue his life although this does not
mean that his legal troubles are over
because they continue uh with the 100
with the dozens of cases which have been
mounted against Imran Khan and what's
been the government's response to this
Osama
well anger and frustration from the
Pakistani government we've heard from
the Prime Minister saying that decisions
like this and favoritism like this means
that this is the death of Justice in
Pakistan why is one man getting such
relief when an ordinary Pakistani cannot
we also saw a gathering of the political
alliance called the Pakistan Democratic
movement which is the ruling Coalition
in Pakistan saying that they are now
going to launch a movement a peaceful
protest movement against the Judiciary
uh for favoriting Imran Khan for giving
him all that he wants and essentially
telling the government and the local
authorities that they cannot prosecute
him for anything that he did they also
talked about the cases that were piled
on against them during Imran Khan's
tenure and they say that Court was even
then giving him relief against all the
corruption that allegedly he was
carrying out some of many things indeed
Al jazeer is Osama Bin Javed there live
in Islamabad